après plusieurs années quand on est
cette dans cette routine de couple à
trois est-ce qu'on apprend à une
quatrième personne et bien pour avoir un
avis extérieur
voir bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle vous publiez donc tous
les trois aux éditions latex un livre
intitulé A3 qui sort le 31 mars ne vous
précipitez pas dès lundi matin c'est le
31 mars vous pouvez le réserver chez
votre libraire habituel voilà et ce
bouquin à trois raconte votre vie de
ménage à trois depuis plus de 20 ans et
la naissance de deux enfants un chacune
deux garçons 1 de Mireille et un de
Catherine voilà alors on va prendre les
choses de zéro 2-0 et pourtant le match
n'est pas commencé enfin il y a des
enfants quand même donc le match est
commencé
donc on va commencer à la formation du
trio hein alors au départ au départ
c'est vous Catherine avec Jean-François
vous vous connaissez vous avez un amour
fusionnel on peut dire vraiment et puis
une grande complicité sexuelle
on peut pas croire
ta femme je la ramène pas tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai au départ au départ
vous êtes vous êtes le noyau dur du
système quand même c'est vous deux
c'est pareil
le cerveau on peut dire beaucoup de
choses au départ c'est vous deux au
départ oui oui à l'arrivée
alors un jour Jean-François vous
demandez à Catherine si elle est déjà
fait l'amour avec une autre femme et
elle vous répond effectivement
j'ai vécu pendant deux ans avec deux
garçons et une fille et vous découvrez
que Catherine aime aussi les femmes
absolument voilà et là c'est le drame
au contraire c'est une histoire
magnifique voilà et c'est vrai vous
Catherine vous avez besoin d'avoir deux
sexes autour de vous vous êtes mieux
quand vous avez un homme et une femme
avec vous voilà c'est tout
et alors à ce moment là Jean-François
vous avez une réaction magnifique vous
dites essayons de trouver cette femme
finalement c'est vrai alors cette
recherche devient quand même un petit
peu une obsession à ce moment là non
à ce moment là c'est vrai qu'on pense
plus qu'à ça heureusement elle arrive
vite au début
précisé on est on est pas un sculpteur
et peintre et je pense que ça c'est
fondamental il fallait trouver quelqu'un
qui était quelqu'un dans le même
histoire voilà même et là c'est la
rencontre avec vous Mireille alors vous
avant vous aviez eu déjà des expériences
comme ça vous voulez dire à plusieurs
non non moi j'étais plutôt
réticente quand j'y crois pas forcément
en fait parce que je me dis c'est pas
possible cette histoire ça marchera pas
et en fait
je dis assez rapidement je l'ai
rencontré assez rapidement et finalement
je m'installe avec eux au bout de deux
mois et demi
qui rencontre Mireille parce que
lorsqu'on a entre guillemets pas
comploté mais lorsqu'on désire cette
troisième personne on est
voilà et comme c'était mon désir avant
le tien finalement toi tu pensais quand
même c'est vrai que c'est un peu normal
que je parte dans une quête par rapport
à cette personne et en fait il entrait
très vite dans cette recherche avec moi
mais je pense que c'était effectivement
logiquement
c'est vous qui l'avez envoyé vous êtes
au courant de ça oui
on l'a décidé ensemble c'est quelque
chose qu'on a décidé ensemble qu'il
passe avec Mireille vous êtes inquiète
bien entendu mais vous n'êtes pas
jalouse
on est obligé de simplifier 25 ans de
vie bon
lorsqu'on l'a vu tous les deux la
première fois lorsqu'on l'invitait à la
maison elle nous a dit oui c'est une
jolie idée de vivre à trois mais c'est
pas pour moi donc on a eu un refus
sympathique il a fallu la séduire alors
voilà vous avez adhéré lentement au
projet du couple en question non
j'ai eu du temps pour pour ça après que
j'ai mis du temps mais au début je suis
finalement j'étais très attirée par eux
et j'ai un peu oublié l'histoire du
couple classique si vous voulez j'ai un
peu occulter ça parce que finalement ce
qui me plaisait c'était l'aventure à
vivre mais j'étais pas du tout ça ça
pouvait durer longtemps alors un jour
vous faites l'amour à trois pour la pour
la première fois c'est un combien de
temps après les avoir rencontrés
assez rapidement et assez rapidement ce
qui est très intéressant dans le bouquin
c'est qu'en fait quand vous faites
l'amour tous les trois c'est jamais tous
les trois actifs en même temps c'est
toujours deux ensemble plus un qui
regarde faire un croquis là parce que je
fais la gueule
je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là
effectivement quand on a commencé à
vivre tous les deux avec Catherine
on a senti assez vite comme beaucoup de
gens certainement l'usure possible de du
couple et et on s'est dit si on
se mettait à la recherche d'une
troisième personne on était d'accord
tous les deux du choix d'une femme par
rapport à l'expérience de Catherine la
vie sa vie précédente et on s'est dit
cette troisième personne en même temps
ça serait un troisième amour mais ça
serait aussi quelqu'un qui serait le
troisième regard la personne qui est
toujours
narbitre en espérant que l'arbitre
tourne vous voyez ce que je disais à
chaque fois chacun l'arbitre plusieurs
années quand on est cette dans cette
routine de couple à trois est-ce qu'on a
pas envie d'une quatrième personne et
bien pour avoir un avis extérieur
[Applaudissements]
figurez-vous que une tentative
il y a des gens qui étaient séduit par
notre histoire il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont voulu vivre à toi j'en connais
plein mais qui passe pas forcément à
l'acte et en fait dans les gens qui
étaient attirés par nous il voulait être
4 mais finalement ça a passé ça faisait
vite 2 et 2 couples donc finalement
voilà
je suis avec ma femme quelque part et je
veux parler elle me coupe la parole mais
vous vous avez deux gonzesses qui vous
coupent la parole donc vous formez en
fait quand vous êtes ensemble formez
trois couples c'est-à-dire le coup
Catherine et Jean-François Jean-François
et Mireille et Mireille et Catherine
elle a interviennent les voisins et là
alors les voisins ne comprennent rien ça
il y a des belles anecdotes
extraordinaire bien sûr voilà donc vous
installez ensemble tous les trois dans
un premier temps après vous prenez une
une ferme retapée dans l'ordre bien plus
tard bien plus tard et vous prenez 4
maîtresses pour vous dire
non on a pour voisin je crois
mais maintenant je sais maintenant je
sais qu'on est voisin et je regrette pas
de de
cette maison dans l'Orne oui absolument
alors vous faites un voyage de noces
tous les trois au Kenya
voyageur
cette expérience moi je vais vous dire
la vérité je crois que dans l'avenir les
gens vivront en solo vivront en duo ou
vivront en trio en quoi tu as c'est
c'est moderne leur truc de rien il
résolvent pas de problème d'abord celui
de la solitude des femmes qui ont pas
trouvé d'hommes puisqu'il y a paraît-il
plus de femmes que d'hommes tout à fait
oui ensuite le problème du logement bon
on nous a souvent dit fait des économies
ça vous intéresse Daniel ça comme
expérience avec Jennifer pas partie
d'homme qui est envie de vivre plus de
soir vous voyez ce que je veux dire le
fantasme parce que on s'aperçoit non
mais on s'aperçoit quand même que c'est
ça reste un grand tabou
nous c'est vrai que ça fait 25 ans qu'on
le vit nos enfants c'est leurs parents
comme ça depuis leur naissance
en premier
vous aussi mais mais bon c'est quand
même Mireille qui est enceinte là la
première personne voilà et ça et ça ça
vous a quand même filé un peu le bourdon
non heureusement ça a duré deux mois
j'ai eu la chance on va avoir une
beaucoup de chance on le reconnaître
dans cette vie bon je crois que j'étais
plus jeune j'explique aussi donc je
voulais j'étais pas tout à fait prête
pour le désir d'enfant ça c'est vrai et
quand Myriam fête est tombé enceinte
j'ai eu le temps de m'inquiéter de moi
finalement c'est ridicule sur une vie
sur le coup c'est très long c'est le
rapport au temps mais
vous n'êtes pas enceinte et Mireille est
enceinte vous dites pardon
il va il m'appartiendra moins c'est
normal puisqu'il aura un enfant avec et
là miracle vous tombez enceinte au bout
de miracle
miracle très concret c'est vrai que
c'était la partie un peu dangereuse
parce qu'on a on a mis quand même trois
quatre ans
j'ai peut-être c'était peut-être moi le
plus réticent parce qu'il est
responsabilité qui va qui dure encore
aujourd'hui qui est quand même
fondamental on n'est pas
là on est d'un coup il y a un côté
jumeau derrière il y a un côté
gémellaire qui s'appelle Raphaël le
vôtre qui s'appelle Octave le vôtre
voilà et vous alors c'est extraordinaire
parce que vous êtes le premier Rome à
avoir été père deux fois en 80 jours
c'est ça c'est pour ça que je dis dans
dans le livre que je suis un peu comme
un comme les lapins et non mais
le lapin de Prévert quoi parce que tout
ça est quand même une envie de vivre un
peu une manière surréaliste
ça correspond tout à fait à la vie
d'artistes donc vous êtes père deux fois
en 80 jours l'infirmière évidemment à
l'hôpital elle doit arriver le mec deux
fois de suite pour deux accouchements à
deux mois d'intervalle elle comprend pas
bien ce qui se passe mais bon vous lui
expliquez quoi moi je repère très vite
qu'elle m'a qu'elle m'a vu il y a deux
mois enfin je veux dire m'a bien fixé
physiquement en plus je suis quand même
un petit peu je suis frisés un peu roux
tout ça et donc je sens à son regard que
je ne vais pas pouvoir lui dire la
vérité donc je lui dis vous avez vu mon
jumeau
et alors sa réponse
par gentillesse me dit mais moi aussi
j'ai une jumelle est-ce que vous êtes
des vrais et là moi j'avais pas lu
Tournier
je ne connaissais rien au vrai au
fausses jumeaux j'ai dit comme vous pour
répondre
lâchement pour chacune d'entre vous
Jean-François c'est à la fois le père de
l'enfant c'est à la fois l'amant et
l'amant de votre amante donc finalement
vous avez une fonction
très rare et quand vous faites c'est
vrai aussi pour pour Mireille et
Catherine parce que parce que je
suis peut-être le seul homme mais on a
on a tous les trois la même fonction
enfin vous voyez ce que je veux dire moi
j'ai une question qu'on met comment vous
faites pour les satisfaire toutes les
deux et qu'elle soit très contente
toutes les deux parce que bon
on s'aime tu compenses avec de l'argent
de poche
il est très beau il est très mignon
mais parfois vous avez pas envie d'être
de plus simple plutôt qu'un plus simple
on peut partir en voyage
parce que si c'est pour refaire les
mêmes choses traditionnel non mais ça
c'est au bout d'un certain temps au
début non on était très très lié tous
les trois tout au début
et apparemment quand j'avais envie
d'être seul on disait allez hop on part
une semaine en vacances par exemple
voilà et puis on racontait ce qui se
passe et tout ça voilà c'est très
intéressant
est-ce que quand par exemple bon il s'en
va en vacances tous les deux vous restez
toute seule est-ce que vous avez envie
de les tromper non non pas du tout alors
là non je suis contente d'être seul je
respire c'est une vie très prenante et
c'est vrai que quand on est on se
retrouve seul c'est un peu pour souffler
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on est dans un
ils ont tous les deux sans personnalité
tous les jours et on est content
[Musique]
curieusement si vous voulez il y a
peut-être beaucoup plus de confiance
que lorsque on se retrouve face à une
seule personne je crois que là
est-ce que vous trouvez pas ça mieux
finalement que d'avoir un amant une
maîtresse cachée dans le placard ah
c'est plus régulier on se connaît mieux
bon les enfants et je sais pas ils
disent maman à tous les deux ou Mireille
par nos présidents
les dimensions du lit
alors il y a qu'aux États-Unis qu'on a
trouvé des supers un grand lit et c'est
vrai c'est vrai que pour blaguer à la
limite les hôtels en France il y a un
grand lit et puis un petit lit pour
l'enfant alors bon on on se qui va dans
le petit livre
quand elles peuvent pas me politiser
et je sais pas de quel côté sortir
pour pouvoir dire très très rapidement
on est passé très vite à chacun sa
chambre la réaction de vos familles
c'était quoi franchement je trouve que
non
parfois
du non dit du respect peut-être c'était
peut-être ta bouche je sais pas mais
beaucoup de non-dit mais du respect donc
ça arrangeait tout le monde sincère
c'est presque même la famille va
découvrir un peu l'histoire parce que
ils nous ont et tous les trois étudiants
aux Beaux-Arts ils nous ont vus vivre
dans un dans un atelier dans Paris et
mais c'est l'arrivée quand on a
annoncé à nos parents respectifs qu'on
allait avoir des enfants là il s'est
vrai que ça leur a fait ce matin
c'est ça le comble je te le dirai après
l'émission
je pense qu'elles sont heureuses aussi
qui ne rêvent pas parmi les femmes
d'avoir une compagne
le nombre de coupes pour toujours besoin
d'avoir une amie en plus
de vous trois partez est-ce que le
couple restant survivrait non c'est pas
possible
différemment et qui en parle normalement
moi je trouve ça génial je me sens tout
à fait normal et puis ça va donner des
bonnes idées à des gens qui
souhaiteraient peut-être vivre ça qui
n'osent pas parce que c'est possible
c'est ça le service public et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu